She's opening for Amy Schumer. Yeah, it should be fun. Great gig.
How much time do you do every night? About 20.
So you're flying first class taking choppers to gigs for 20 minutes that.
Feel money's great. The hotels are great. Five star hotels, generous, loyal,
giver. All these. She gets so much hate these people. She's a great gal.
I don't know what they're talking about.
Traveling with her and staying in five star hotels. That's a good point.
But Amy's always been a very generous and very cool. So, uh,
but what is the,
do you even feel like you're working if you're only doing 20 minutes.
And you're back the same night and he just made a ton of dough and you got to do
the thing you love and be pampered. I mean, I hate to be that guy,
but it's great. The hotel and I wouldn't want to be her.
I wouldn't want to be the headliner.
It's even better because I get to just open and then I'm done.
Just having drinks and flirting with chicks.
That's it? Yeah. Am I going to BJ in the back? I mean, if Kenny's available,
but uh, yeah, it's just, it's the dream. It's late. A lot of her shows,
Oh my dude. It's 10 million or 10,000 people and me going, Oh, I'm single. Huh?
Yeah. So it's, it's open game on the Tinder. Is there any,
it's always a subtle thing that comics do. Like I'm a single or, uh, yeah.
You know, I love cocaine or it's hard to lug in this wide car.
Say no, no.
I was just going to ask him if there's any guilt associated with the fact that
you don't feel like you're really worried.
Oh, of course. I got crazy guilt. I have guilt when Roland gets me a sandwich.
So yeah, I'm a guilt ridden nutjob, but I just trying to be about that.
I have guilt issues. I have real bad guilt,
but how long have you been doing stand-up? 10 years. 10 years.
You're making money. You're traveling.
I think this is a normal thing. That's why I asked him not asking me. Cause he,
I feel like he's damaged or something,
but I would think that if you're flying first class staying in the best hotels,
I also know she's very generous with taking you guys out to eat.
I know everything about this. Yeah.
And then you're literally on stage for 20 minutes. I, I would almost,
I think I would feel that guilt.
Total guilt. And like, if you don't do well, Oh my God. Talk about guilt.
You feel horrible. Don't do well. Is it because the crowd wants to see Amy?
Yeah. Usually, or, you know, maybe you're off.
Maybe you're nervous and you can't get the jokes out. Right. The timing's off.
But yeah. I mean, if you bomb, I bombed one or two times in a,
in a theater and it is by the way,
bombing is hard to bombing in front of 10,000 is brutal. That's a loud silence.
Uh, but yeah, I mean, I feel guilty.
I'll I have these weird issues where I think my parents were kind of up and
they, they screwed me up. But uh,
I'll I love smoothies and I'll walk by a smoothie place and I'm like, God,
you got a smoothie. I'm like, well, what the do you think you are?
Just to be able to get a smoothie and I'll just walk right by it.
I'm an idiot. I don't know. It's weird. I won't eat certain things. I'm like,
I'm looking at cookies. Know what do you think? You just deserve a cookie. you,
you piece of before in my life. What is that? Based on?
I think my parents didn't give anything. We had no food in the house as a kid.
And, and you know, either all by you gotta earn, you've got to work hard.
I don't know where.
I didn't have a lot of food in the house.
So now I make sure if I want a smoothie, I'm getting a gods.
You're healthy. I, uh, I got problems. I don't know what.
Current issues also have issues. Jesus. Yeah.
We got something it's hard to get to where he's at so he can appreciate what you
guys have worked hard to get where you're at.
But you know these guys, you just see them walking into a basket Robbins.
You're like, what the did you get promoted? No. Then get the hell out of here.
You don't deserve that. Where are you walking around? Starving all the time.
I am a hungry. That's why I'm so thin. When do you treat yourself? Ah,
when I'm hammered. I usually do. Oh well cause then,
cause the inhibitions are all gone, you know? And then he'd just eat food. I.
Just anything. I Kia furniture size women. I mean,
it's crazy.
Wait, I know we've got a break, but you're in a, you're in a city.
You just had a good show.
Now you're walking around a cool area that has like smoothie shots.
Yes. You're staying in the nice part too. Where do do you go into.
Any of these places? Because you're just simply hungry.
Isn't it now. And I, you know, I'm like, Oh,
there's a mint on the pillow at the hotel. Eat that that's free, you know? Oh,
there's a roll on that dead food service tray on the floor. I'll get that.
This is real. Oh, but mess. You can ask my friends. They've all seen it.
They're like, dude, like I'll be with Joe list. I'll be like,
I'm going to get a dollar slice. He's like, dude, you make good money,
go get a Joe's slice. I'm like, nah, I gotta get the dollar.
But we went and had nice burgers in the Austin you paid is that was a
funny thing. It's like, who am I to just give this guy a piece of paper?
And then I get a burger. Get the hell out.
When you hook up with any of Amy's fans. Yes.
Do you ever feel guilty because they're her fans and you them.
Not because they're her fans. They still chose to me.
And I think it's a money thing. It's a money and food thing really.
But I think also, uh, you know,
some of the Amy fans become Mark Norman fans to cross over there.
Should I just got a new apartment and I have no furniture in it. Cause I'm like,
I don't deserve, I'll look at like a nice couch.
I'm like this couch is not for me. That's big nugget, Lucy. Kay.
Bought me a watch after the gigs. You know?
I don't know if I'm supposed to say that,
but he bought me a really nice watch and I can't wear it because it's too nice.
So I just, it's kind of a waste. I'm walking around my apartment,
my underwear with a watch. I'm looking in the mirror going, Hey, look at this.
So do you feel like eventually you'll be able to wear the watch and go to the
smoothie shop? Like [inaudible] Like, do you feel like, all right,
maybe if I get a sitcom or a movie or is there some kind of goal
in your mind where you go now I'll be able to.
Treat myself. I think if I get a sitcom,
I'll buy myself a smoothie and that'll be my reward. And then it's back to hell.
Holy. Do you talk to anyone about this? I got a therapist. Wow.
How often do you see your therapist? Once a week. Yeah. Great guy.
He thinks he's like, just buy the smoothie. You earned it. He's like he can't,
he's got all this. Like you don't love yourself.
What's the point who's no one else is going to buy is really well. You know?
Where does your therapist think it comes from? Uh, he thinks it's all parents,
but how about this Schumer? This is years ago.
I broke up my girlfriend and I gave her my apartments. I was like, you take it.
I just want to be away from you. So you take the apartment,
I'll find a new apartment.
I left a bunch of over there and it was such a bad breakup.
I couldn't go back over there. And she had my coat. It's dead of winter.
It's like January, 2014.
She bought me a coat because I was just walking around in like a hoodie in the
middle of winter. And she was like, what are you doing? I'm freezing my balls.
I'm like, I don't have a coach. He's like, where's your coat? I'm like,
I left at my girlfriend's house. Why don't you go get it? I can't face her.
Well, why don't you go buy one? I can't buy a coat. It's too much money.
I don't deserve that. And she bought me one. You wouldn't buy a coat.
That Patagonia coat she paid for. And that's now three years old. Yeah.
That's a weird thing though, because you can afford a click and afford.
There's a difference. Yeah. There's a difference between like,
I don't want this watch because it's too nice for me.
I don't want to eat this because I feel like that's kind of like something you
should do. If you're, if you're more successful, when you're cold,
you need a coat. Ah, dovetail. Tell me about it. I was freezing,
but how do you justify that in your head that you don't buy yours?
Cause I'm like, who am I to get a coat? I'm not a fun guy.
I'm not a buyer. I can't walk into a store. Buy a coat is a privilege.
Yes.
I think no matter who you are and how much money you make, we're all coping.
Guys. Yeah. Every once in a while it's like, everyone's a Coke guy.
Everyone is a shoes. Guy has shoes, everybody. Well, look,
I got the square shoes on the planet because there's a new balance.
That's your thing. All right.
Are you to have new balance Slack kick out and buy these Jordans.
These kids are wearing.
I'm going to blow your mind. Why was it okay to take the coat from Amy?
I think it was a gift. So if it's a gift that's okay. I guess.
So it doesn't make sense. So have your friends at the smoothie store go,
here's a gift for you today? Well, they don't speak English, but Hey,
I thought we were going to break. No, this is,
this is way better than anything else. It's fascinating.
It's really fascinating.
So he was okay with you buying him the burgers in Austin.
He's okay with Amy buying him this nice coat. You hide it though, man?
Yeah.
I didn't know anything about, I mean,
we've hung out a little bit here and there socially.
You hide this stuff because it looks like you're dressed. Nice. And.
I got this shirt for doing Colbert. It's a free t-shirt.
Well, I mean, I'm not just talking about today's shirt in general. I would,
I would assume you, you shop for yourself.
Yeah. You don't look like a guy who's trying to save money. Oh, that's good.
How many pair of jeans do you have to?
And I basically only wear this one, the other one's like my lawn mow and jeans,
you know? And that's it. And that's it. Yeah.
What do you need more than two for minimalist? I'm a minimalist in general,
but I got one pair of shoes.
A couple of shirts and we got a couple pairs of jacket.
I'm almost there with you. I mean, we didn't have a lot of money growing up.
So I, there is some guilt with me, but not to that extent.
I'm going to buy myself a smoothie every time.
And if I get that smoothie, the guilt it all day long, like what the?
Who do you think you are, you know, money bags, your piece of.
What are you getting a smoothie? What if you run out of money?
What if you don't make it know? It's it never ends.
So I'd rather just not have it and go, you know, live a anxiety-free you lived.
In that pretty awesome house down there in new Orleans. I mean,
it seemed like your parents had money.
Well, that's the thing, this, this, this is where it all stems from.
My dad bought a mansion, a dilapidated mansion in a poor black neighborhood.
So on the front it looks like we got money, but in the inside there's termites,
rats, pigeons. We don't have running water.
So I kind of have this look of wealth, but it's all of a sudden,
you say, Hey, you don't look poor and I'm not poor, but you don't look balmy,
but it's all, I'm a bum inside. Just like the house.
Yes. That's fascinating. Was deep. That's fascinating stuff. Oh yeah. I mean,
we get robbed all the time and these guys would come and be like,
where the is everything. Right? We were like, Hey, welcome to our world.
You know, like home invasions people would, Oh my God, we got robbed. You know,
once every three months, Jesus, it's frightening.
We were the white guys on the block with the mansion. So everybody's like, Hey,
we got to get in there.
Did your parents ever think let's get the out of this name?
Well, they're so liberal and they're so progressive that, you know, my bike,
we get stolen all the time. A couple of guys took my bike off of me once.
And I was like, I ran home crying. I was like 10. And I was like, Oh,
these guys stole my bike. And my mom's like, well, they need it. No,
they need it more at all. Don't worry about it. We'll get you a new bike,
you know, whatever. And I was like, but I like that bike. Ah. I think.
You just explain why you don't like talking politics.
No, I just don't. I, my brain goes off when I hear politics. Right. You know?
Well, cause you it's all nonsense.
And the [inaudible] side thinks their sides the best. And in the end,
they're both. Both sides are.
Same with sports. I can't get into it. Cause I'm like, it's all just, okay.
A ball went to hoop who gives a, he got points. He didn't, I don't know.
None of it matters to me. Right. But I get why sports are great.
And I get why politics are interesting. I just, it's not.
Has the therapist made any headway as far as you treating yourself to anything?
A little, but I push it down. I push it down. Like in what way?
Any kind of progress in being able to enjoy life like a normal person?
Not much, but I'm aware of it, but like more aware of it. Yeah.
But here's one thing I do. I'll take girls out and I splurge.
Big dinners drank really want y'all yeah. Hey, let's get a ride here.
It's Uber's everywhere. Taxis everywhere. Let's get a nice hotel,
big money because it's for her, not for me and that, that I can do.
And you're taking it and you're reaping the rewards of it.
That I'm reaping the war and you can lay it and I'm on, on a date, you know,
because have to buy a place. You bought a place, a lot of place. But I mean,
I saved up for years and I just, I I'm only doing,
I'm only able to do it cause it's such a good investment.
That's what I keep telling him.
That's what I was going to ask you because.
You're going to get laid from the places.
You gotta make money off it eventually. Yeah. But you can't buy furniture.
I have no furniture. So what's in your house.
A mattress on the floor, like a assassin.
That kind of rules. No, I'm not even kidding.
I mean, every girl that comes over, I'm like, I just moved in a week ago.
You don't have a couch yet. Now I got no couch TV. I have a TV.
Cause there was one in the apartment when that one in the apartment. Yeah.
That's the only reason I wifi eventually. Cause I had work to do, you know,
I had to like do work. So I had to get a. So that makes sense to you. Yeah.
We're not cable. I got cable, but I never watch it. I should watch it.
But you're paying for cable. I'm paying for cable. You deserve, you buy.
Yeah. I don't buy groceries. I don't eat at home. You just get,
take out or whatever. Yeah. A lot of eating out a lot of comedy club food,
whatever. So the one thing you'll splurge on is women.
Have you been in a relationship long enough where you just stop?
Cause you're like, eh. Yeah.
And I start to resent them with like this horse is running out my bank account
and then you break up with them because they're like, what's the problem. Like.
They can.
And she's just trying to get toilet paper for your apartment.
[Inaudible] that is fascinating. I love this. We're getting too deep here.
If you don't mind, this is not don't mind, but I'm good.
I'm telling you right now. I don't want to bore anybody in Canada.
It's fascinating. It's weird that it kind of bothers you a little bit too.
Well it's it's a curse.
Yeah. And I get, I get guilt to a certain extent,
but this is way further in your spending. You mean not? Yeah.
And just in general, like just talking but not.
Not in what form is your guilt?
Um, that's a good question. Let me think.
I steal a lot too. Which is a problem when you're drunk,
you steal more when you're drunk. Tons of stealing.
But I steal from like Walmart or Walgreens or I don't steal from like a person's
house. Is that okay? Because I feel like that's a corporation. They're fine.
Pocket from Starbucks all the time. Do you see all the that you don't need?
That's always food or so I don't steal like, like a snow globe, you know?
But I'll be at the airport. I'm like, Oh, these prices are crazy.
I'll just steal a sandwich and they don't notice it. Oh, I'm the King. Yeah.
While you're traveling with Amy, not really with Amy, be like,
if I'm going to meet her and I'm flying somewhere to meet her. Yeah.
I'll steal from the airport all the time.
What if I got popped here and I had to tell Amy, I got caught.
I think about that all the time. Yeah. I'm so good.
How have you been good?
I mean, I got popped when I was like 11. I was stole a cause I was like,
what's a. You know,
I knew it was like vaginal and I stole a from Rite aid and they caught me and
they were like, what are you doing with this dude? I was like, my mom's sick.
I made up this whole thing. The guys, I gotta get the hell out of here. No,
I was trying to learn vaginally. You thought maybe you could it.
This is pre-Google. Yeah. Maybe a little. I thought it was last week.
Yeah. Close to get.
He ever thought somebody was eyeballing you when you were stealing something and
thought Holy. In your heart. Yeah, of course. And then I aboard. I mean,
I'm not dumb. I know when to pull out, you know.
Lean a little bit to him. No, because if, if, uh,
I leave a store with something, I have no guilt. Cause I think the same thing.
It's a corporation of these, but everything is over overpriced to begin.
We'll never know. They'll never know. them.
It might get away with a little something every once in a while.
I have no problem with it.
No, nothing, none. That's why I like that. Winona Ryder. I totally get it. Yeah.
I'm like, ah, it. Steel.
Thrill. It's a thrill. It's a good time. So when you're eating out,
it has to be just basic stuff. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Totally.
I mean, I go to Chipotle a lot. Just,
just something that's like quick 10 bucks or less. And I'm full.
I love finding out like I hate topless and like that.
I love finding out why you guys are comics. I finally figured out Mark.
He gave us this. We didn't, uh, I mean, it makes a lot of sense.
I don't even get these comics go up there and go, Hey, what the?
You don't laugh. Who gives a? you. It's like, no, make them laugh.
That's your job. Your piece of. Make them laugh. Right.
I hate these lazy comics. They give us a bad name too. Right?
I don't give you guys laugh and go to a park, yelled a pigeon.
Why are you in this comedy club? But this full audience, that page.
So that's why you work so hard. Yeah. That's a big part of it.
Four or five sets a night. Guilt.
If people don't know, Mark works really hard.
At this most sets in New York. Really? Oh yeah. It's been documented.
It's been done most sets in New York like in a night.
Like I think in a year span. I'll do like four nights. I did four last night.
I did four on Tuesday. Wednesday. What happens if you do one or two?
I feel horrible. Horrible. I'm like, Oh, come on. What are you doing?
I got the easiest job. Best job in the world. I can't do more than one set.
Come on.
Only because you couldn't get booked for more shows.
Yeah. Something will come up or you know, a show got canceled.
Are you, are your parents proud of you?
Maybe that's what I'm looking for. I mean, they're not mad at me.
They're just like, yeah. You know, you're whatever you're doing your thing.
They're casual battery. Very casual. This is what my parents do.
This is when my therapist goes in on and that we'll get out of here.
I'll go in my house. Are you calling the break? Well, I just feel bad.
I'm hogging it here. So I go to my grades,
I go to my parents' house and they'll just be like, Hey, how you doing?
Good to see it. And they'll drop a stack of magazines,
newspapers and whatever on the table. And they go,
those have comedy in mentioned in it and I go, Oh, all right.
Because they know I like comedy. So they're like, yeah,
that's mentioned in there. I'm like, okay,
so now I don't want to be a Dick because they thought about me.
So I sit there with a reading glasses on and a highlighter and I go through and
I go, Oh, there's the comedy. Cause I want to make them feel good for caring.
Even though they're not around.
Anymore to see that you're going to look at the articles.
And they know that this is the least amount of care they can give.
But in their mind, I'm like, Hey, this is looking at, we give a. All right.
They don't care. Their care doesn't go like much deeper than, yeah.
I don't think so. I mean, if I'm on call and they go, Hey, you're on call.
How cool is that? But they don't. I don't know if they're like.
Final question. What do you think they did to that? That's such a nice room.
What was that trigger?
My mom just yelled and screamed all the time. It was exhausting.
To what you do today. I.
Used to be a yeller and screamer. Most interested, not, not so much in, uh, um,
uh, many years now.
To be honest. Is that part of why you went to therapy? Uh,
I went to therapy cause yeah, between, you know.
The new life with my wife and kids and all that I finally was like, all right.
I always thought that therapy who needs that. That's great.
But then you realize, Oh no, this is actually good. And could really help you.
So.
It sounds like you cured your, so your got you cured. I feel like I'm in.
A good place. I don't know. I mean, I think everyone could, could use, um,
someone to talk to and you know, I checked in from time to time, but yeah,
there was a lot of awareness that came just talking to somebody. Totally.
And that's the first step.
Has ever had a therapy session that, uh, turned into a breakdown.
Few of them I've had that
[inaudible] as a joke, Steve McQueen.
That it was time to move on. And my therapist actually said,
you're good for now.
Wow. I don't know if we should ever actually say never.
You said at the time she was like, you know, you're good.
We can take some time off because I started talking about the time I didn't get
a bike when I was young.
Oh yes. You're reaching.
I don't know what else to talk about. So I start reaching and, and she,
I guess she knows that it's her job. So she's like, yeah. You know what?
You're good. That's really, that matters. Happens all the time.
Oh, that's a red flag. Why you thought she was mom? Oh no.
[inaudible] you said you were yelling and screaming for awhile and now you're
not. So I think that's a good set of why, because you realize.
I would get very frustrated. I, I had what was called a irritable depression,
which is a depression that comes on when you're just frustrated and you're
irritable and you don't know how to get it out. And so like,
I'd be really frustrated about things going on at work,
maybe at home or whatever. And I would yell and scream.
But that what you learn is when you're yelling and screaming,
people just think you're an. They're not going to listen to you.
Even though in your, in your heart, you know,
you're right about this certain point.
There are times you just know you're right. I think,
and other times it's open for discussion. Obviously I'm just fighting. Right,
right. But things at work where I'm like, no,
I know this is how it should be done, whatever. So, but when you're screaming,
bloody murder, everyone just thinks you're a.
And then now they're not listening to the point you're actually trying to make.
Did you scream and yell at people at work? Not anymore. When,
when you went through the therapy, did you then go back and apologize?
Try to make amends with people.
To a lot of people.
Over the years. And did anyone go you?
Uh, not to my face, but I'm sure they're like, yeah, whatever.
I'm still not over.
Oh. So you can kind of feel it, you know? But you, you, you do what you can.
Yeah.
You can do what you can. I apologize for a whole bunch of things.
So what do you think your parents did though? Me?
It was definitely the yelling thing just drove me insane.
For me. It was the exact number. There was zero connecting. It was zero. I mean,
they said, I love you. And that was some shoulder padding, not a lot of hugs,
but, uh, it was, I think it was just, there was no connection.
They were busy at work. They come home. They go, you're the kid.
Here's a piece of. You know, here's a chicken leg. And uh, yeah, that was it.
You know, if I'd be like, Hey dad, I'm pulling on his pant leg. Hey,
I did this it's school to go. Yeah. Yeah. Whatever, go watch TV, older brother.
How's he get more attention.
Than you can see. Does he go and get up?
No, he's got some problems too. And he's, but he's a certified genius.
Listen to this rap sheet on my brother certified genius went to the best high
school in new Orleans, skipped his senior year to go straight to Berkeley,
full scholarships. He's going to Berkeley. It's like a 17 year olds, like duty.
How's their shoes. Yeah. Then he became a master fencer who fences.
We get a master fencer, did a whole bunch of toured the world with fencing,
these championships. Then he joined the peace Corps in Africa,
helping poor kids on a, in a village, learn math.
So they could engineer and build pipes and you know, whatever. And, uh,
they did that for two. I went and visit them. It was hell.
I mean talking female circumcision, the whole thing. And uh,
now he works for Google. He's like a millionaire living in new Orleans. Wow.
Yeah. And I'm a comedian.
I think you're, I think your life's better. How about that?
How about that? He, no, he's married with kids and he's always tells me,
like pulls me aside after a few beers. And he goes, don't do it really. Yeah.
Which is interesting, but a weird Mark.
If it's better,
but he's like imprisoned in his own psyche says the same thing.
He's like.
Somehow you got to have a breakthrough. I, I need a breakthrough.
All you're going to need is just a little breakthrough.
You'll start seeing that light. And then yeah, man, things starts to make sense.
Especially when doing that gig regularly, working with Amy.
I did some tours with bands. I opened for Alison Chainz. Everything was like,
so pampered every yeah. That I really thought, I've worked so long for this.
This is an awesome feeling. And then when it ended and I went back to my own,
whatever my own regular, uh, comedy thing was, it was like, I, you know,
I knew to enjoy it at the time when it happened.
I can't believe that you don't allow yourself to enjoy it while it's happening.
And that's what a great gig.
Weird thing I'll do is I'll go to a lot of pictures on Instagram and I'll go
through them from like a year or two ago. No, no. I'm like,
look how cool that was all. Look at that. And I go, wow,
look at that and blow up like, who is this guy? That is amazing. And I'm like,
that's you, you.
[Inaudible] can I see it later? I can look at that. Wow.
That is fascinating too, because Mark is one of the good ones on Instagram.
I'm a follower. I like your stuff all the time.
He has a very good eye for photography. Try to make it a good photo or else.
You're very serious about your Instagramming. Thank you.
Funny now that connection is really kind of interesting. Yes, exactly.
I'm trying to capture that moment cause I can't enjoy it. So maybe you should.
So say should just take pictures of smoothies for now. I wish.
So you tried to capture an image. That's good. Funny or good. Like, wow.
This is a great moment in my life.
It's a little of both, but it's mostly look at this moment. Look,
I'm in a jet right now with this superstar or I'll look at this arena I'm doing
or whatever the hell, you know, and uh, yeah. Some are funny, silly,
totally disconnected.
Silly too. But I mean, in general, you're very artistic with your photos.
It's Martin Mormon on Instagram. We should take a break cause uh,
my cat is waiting the hall and uh, Mark she's.
Yeah. Well, thanks for letting me know. This is really fascinating. Hey,
anytime I appreciate the, the, the listening. No one else listens. Oh really?
Yeah. Who the hell am I? Can I cut? What am I going to go? Hey mom,
you've reached the wrong number, but as you're saying that out loud,
is there any kind of realization that you're having, as you're saying all that,
but it's like being left-handed, it's just, that's how I am. I can't rewire it.
I guess I can really try it and be right-handed but it's going to take,
you know, a lot of work.
Why don't I, I got to keep going back to this.
Why don't you feel like you deserve to buy anything?
I think it has a lot to do with that house as a kid.
I think it had a lot to do with, uh, not being,
if you're not treated as a human being, as a child,
it just sticks with you. That's how your, your, your wiring is set.
How are you not treated like a human being?
Just like the zero attention zero who, you know, we don't,
you're not even there. You're not,
you're not looking past any attention that you were given.
You really believe that you had zero attention. It was pretty low. Yeah.
You know, all the, the love I needed it was it wasn't there.
How did you know it was low? Were you able to compare it to your brother? No,
I just that's life, but it,
I only reason I know as low as cause of these symptoms I have now. Right?
So he got the same zero,
but he put it all in the work and he's made a lot of money and he's got a family
now who he loves. So he he's smarter than me. He made it work.
I'm doing it with audiences. He's doing it with a family and money and a home.
Then in Brooklyn says you're just cheap.
Plastic, Brooklyn answer.
I wasn't deflecting. I was trying to think. And then we went back to Mark.
The guilt with me goes with, uh, when things are going well,
because my house in my house,
there was never a time where things were going well, there was always a problem.
Right? Christmas is a, even though they tried their best, we're always.
Cause my mom had a lot of Christmases.
So she brought the mood down every Christmas and then you're there as a kid,
opening up your cool new stuff.
And you almost felt guilty cause you were happy and enjoying,
enjoying.
That is heavy. And this went.
And laid into my life where like,
even when I was having success with the radio show over the years and stuff,
I felt guilty like, Oh, things are good. It's they're never supposed to be good.
I would come home with some exciting news and my mom would be off and running
because sneakers were left out some nonsense.
And it was always supposed to just be just, just negative and sad in the house.
Yes. So I had to get through that,
but I got the breakthrough and I I'm certainly enjoying my life way more now,
but it took,
it took a long time because you don't even understand why you have the guilt at
first. You're like, why am I guilty? Because you know, I'm happy.
And the radio shows going well and I, you know.
You have to rewire your whole system. It's not easy. It takes a while.
So you weren't even able to realize that that guilt was always there until you
went to bed.
Yeah. That's right. We're not supposed to be, you know, kind of happy. Right.
You know, you kinda knew,
and that was the guilt because you would leave this depressing situation,
go back to my apartment in this case and, and then be happy and like, uh,
you know, and then feeling the guilt. Like you're, you know, it's yeah.
That attachment to the, uh, the house or whatever. So how man.
This is a heavy yeah, great. This is fine. We got to take a break. My poor guys.
They're just bored.
By it. He's giving me the, come on, wrapping up, wrapping.
Up. This is the good there. Eric, who cares? If we have to break,
I'm not going to stop Mark. When he says he can't buy a smoothie.